veamos algunos estudios estadísticos y
tratemos de descubrir qué tipo de
estudios son una tienda de juguetes
recibe un envío de 100.000 patitos de
hule de la fábrica la fábrica no puede
asegurar que todos los patitos sean
perfectos pero asegura que el porcentaje
de patitos defectuosos no será mayor al
5% vamos a resaltar esto el porcentaje
5% si quiere obtener un estimado del
porcentaje de juguetes defectuosos y
como no se pueden revisar los 100.000
patitos se toma una muestra aleatoria de
10 patitos y se encuentra que el 10 por
ciento están defectuosos qué es lo que
sucede aquí se recibe un envío hay
100.000 patitos en el envío y se quiere
obtener un estimado del porcentaje de
estos que están defectuosos no podemos
revisar los 100.000 patitos ya que es
poco práctico por lo que se toma una
muestra aleatoria de 10 patitos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9
y se encontró que uno de estos diez
patitos estaba defectuoso 10% de los
diez primero que nada vemos que este es
un estudio de muestreo como lo sabemos
pues nos dicen que se toma una muestra
aleatoria de una población más grande
para poder estimar un parámetro el
parámetro es el porcentaje de patitos
defectuosos de los 100.000 patitos
recibidos la otra pregunta es qué tipo
de conclusión podemos tener aquí nos
dicen que se tomó una muestra aleatoria
y se encontró defectuoso el 10 por
ciento de esta muestra y quizá con esto
podríamos estar bastante molestos porque
la fábrica no se aseguró que el
porcentaje de patitos defectuosos no
sería mayor al 5% por lo que no están
cumpliendo su promesa ya que revisamos
10 juguetes y el 10 por ciento de esos
diez juguetes estuvo defectuoso bueno
esta no es una conclusión razonable ya
que esta es una muestra muy pequeña
piensen en ello pudimos saber muestreado
sólo 5 juguetes y si resultará que
revisamos uno de los defectuosos
diríamos que el 20% están defectuosos lo
que aquí se tiene que hacer es tomar una
muestra mucho más grande y sea lo que
sea que estemos muestreando nuestro
estimado puede que no esté cerca o no
sea igual al parámetro de la población
pero mientras más grande sea nuestra
muestra va a aumentar la probabilidad de
que nuestro estimado se acerque al
parámetro real de la población y en este
caso sólo 10 elementos es algo muy
pequeño en futuros vídeos veremos cómo
podemos estimar la probabilidad o cómo
descubrir si nuestra muestra es
suficiente pero para este caso no creo
que 10 patitos sean suficientes para
hacer esto quizás si muestra éramos unos
100 patitos o más que esto y aún así
encontramos que el 10% está defectuoso
pues es más probable entonces que esto
no se deba al azar en futuros vídeos
resolveremos más problemas de éstos